welcome back to the show friends and
family
fast nine is releasing in theaters at
the end of this month so today
we are covering what is now considered a
favorite in the fast franchise that
arguably turned a lot of people into
fans and carried the franchise to where
it is today
and may have inspired the guy talking
right now to get more excited about f9
that is of course the fastest of the
furious tokyo
drift the movie is 37 percent
rotten on the tomato meter but it does
have a 69
fresh audience score and our guest today
i am so excited to talk to her as well
as our co-host jacqueline coley but
our guest is the drift queen herself
jen yamato she is a film critic i'm sure
you know and a co-host of the la times
podcast
asian enough and she's gonna give us a
sneak peek into her thoughts on this
movie
what it means for the future of the
franchise what it means about the world
at large
jen i am so excited to talk to you about
this justice for han indeed
i kick off with a question we ask
everyone is rotten tomatoes
wrong about tokyo drift well
i have to say first of all the rotten
tomatoes audience score
nice nice going guys uh the critic score
however
i'm so disappointed rotten tomatoes is
wrong
all right ron tonight is a resounding
wrong
from jen although she does agree with
the audience score but maybe
it could be even a little bit higher
brian let's get that show intro music
cooking my man
in a moment we're gonna break down how
we feel about this film and we're gonna
do some behind the scenes trivia later
on in the show
as we always do but first jacqueline
coley you are here joining me as always
in 30 seconds or less or gone in 60
seconds perhaps
tell us what is tokyo drift all about
well in tokyo drift we follow a new cast
of characters to the french
a fast and furious franchise namely
the main character played by lucas black
he plays sean boswell who he's been in
trouble
for his entire life because of women and
cars and so he gets into some trouble
with a very aggro
sort of uh high schooler at the
beginning of this and he is shipped off
to tokyo
and upon arriving in tokyo even though
he shows absolutely no reason for an
entire host of asian people to think
that he's worthy of their attention
or their love he becomes the center
narrative and
mostly due to the fact that girls just
love him as the outsider but mostly
because han liu adopts him into
his sort of crew he is the partner of
the tokyo drift king
played by brian t and throughout the
course of the film sean gets
deeper into the underworld of tokyo
drift street racing
he figures out in a matter of a montage
how to be great at it
and through the host of a bunch of
minority characters that lift him up
throughout
he becomes the king of all and races dom
toretto at the end
and if that synopsis does not tell you
how i feel about mr
lucas black and sean boswell i hope you
understand it now
but in all things the cars
the style justin lin's direction and of
course i will add
mr suk sung kang playing han lu uh
playing han louie is perfect so there
you go thank you at least for that shout
out and i will note it's like two
montages it takes him to learn how to
drift properly so
you know one montage can get you a clean
uh
fraternity house and revenge of the
nerds but you need two montages
to learn how to drift properly we
welcome in
producie lucy hello lucy hi
real quick shout out i have a new
celebrity crush
han oh okay yes
okay yes he's worthy of crush
he's been worried they've crushed for a
while though but yeah after this
i'm gonna google a youtube a billion
interviews with him okay that's all much
better look
watch better look tomorrow first then do
that because you need to see better look
tomorrow because he's even more
dreamy and better luck tomorrow in my
personal opinion it is one of the things
that i was enlightened to from our
expert researcher mark hoffmeyer is the
order to watch the fast movies in and
apparently
i think i'm actually doing okay just
because i came to tokyo drift
as of this podcast like this is the
first time that i saw
the movie never seen it before and man
am i pumped to talk about it i'll ask
jacqueline first because we already got
jen's opinion on whether rotten tomatoes
is wrong jaclyn
we heard your synopsis is rotten
tomatoes wrong
about tokyo drift rotten tomatoes
would be wrong if they deleted the
entire sean character
then this movie in my opinion would be
75
certified fresh at least because
everything else in this movie is
amazing but because of him and i'm
literally putting this
all on his on his shoulders this movie
deserves its score
but it's only because of him wow okay
lucas black not the broadest shoulders
in the world so
that's going to be tough for him to bear
i'm going to say that rotten tomatoes
is wrong because i agree with jen yamato
i really had a ball watching this movie
so much so that it reminded me why i
love the fast and furious movies in the
first place and why i've sort of gotten
away from them a little bit because
obviously we're talking about this movie
fast nine or f9 or furious nine it's
it's a fast and furious movie it's the
ninth one and it's coming out soon in
theaters may already be out in some
places and
this movie got me pumped to go see
f9 i didn't go to some of the press
screenings i was very nice to be offered
but i didn't want to go and now i kind
of want to go
more now than ever so we're going to
hear our opinions on the movie scenes on
behind the scenes and again a couple
trivia questions at the end of the show
but before we do any of that let's hear
from our review curation manager
the one the only tim ryan for two
minutes
with tim
[Music]
to get this out of the way at the top
the critics basically felt that the fast
and the furious tokyo drift had lots of
awesome car stuff
very little character development or
memorable dialogue
and a decided lack of vin diesel and
paul walker
later installments of the fast and
furious franchise would tie
tokyo drift into the overall narrative
but when it came out in 2006 it was sort
of greeted by critics anyway
as an attempt to keep a franchise moving
without its charismatic stars this
movie's acquired something of a
cult classic status as part of the
franchise but
it was easy at the time to think that
well this franchise is
kind of out of steam it was kind of a
box office disappointment when it came
out in 2006
it's opening weekend it finished behind
another car movie called
cars and also nacho libre so
yeah the fast and the furious tokyo
drift is rotten at 37
on the tomato meter with 137 reviews but
it does have a 69
audience score so what did the critics
have to say in a rotten review michael
wilmington the chicago tribune wrote
for all its crashes and flash this is a
movie that drifts away
as we watch it muscle cars and all it's
often a waste of gas
however in a fresh review michael sragao
of the baltimore sun wrote
the opening half hour may prove to be a
disreputable classic of pedal to the
metal filmmaking
so anyway folks that's the fast and the
furious
tokyo drift was this one spinning its
wheels
or did it cross the finish line or car
things that is our guy tim ryan yeah
this movie
does itself no favors with the critics
simply because it's based around cars
and so you're going to get a lot of
those
so many people out of gas oh my gosh
themselves can i can i have to interject
something i've known tim ryan rotten
tomatoes editor tim ryan
for so long because i too
once worked at rotten tomatoes and i was
listening to
one of your recent episodes about the
major motion picture
titanic and i
do believe tim might have left out a
very important detail
i i always thought if i'm remembering
this right
that tim might have seen that movie like
six or seven times in the theater
i do remember him talking about this
actually he did talk about titanic
and how many times that did not make it
into this two minutes with tim two
minutes
oh wow anyway okay well we got to give
lucy remind us to give tim three minutes
next week so he can explain himself with
the whole
titanic thing and we should make another
note when we're talking about water
movies is that
uh jack when i got our fans very excited
last week talking about this deep blue
sea musical that i thought was real that
we hoped was real
we don't actually know if it's real we
don't think it's real so mark hoffmeyer
sorry to get you out of bed you can go
back and take a nap now we don't believe
deep sea
uh deep lucy is a real musical but we do
know
is real it's a real play i actually
figured
it's a real play that actually starred
the late
helen mccrory who just recently passed
damian lewis's wife
it was a play that's why so he did
direct it it was his thing but it's not
the llc wait was it a play based on the
movie though no
not at all there that's where
so you can ask anybody including katy
perry's halftime show it's hard to pull
off sharks
in performance art like that so let's
get away from that tangent and
wait wait wait wait wait look at that
back onto the track perhaps
okay get back on the track but i to just
quickly use the car analogy you can't i
don't know
i know i just want to give a shout out
to ogrt
jen is an og r t i just want to shout
her out because she knows where the
bodies are buried
that's it no this is a cool connective
tissue that we have it's almost like
we're building our own
fast and furious crew because people are
coming back into the fold now and it's
exciting and we're all
here today and this movie
for a long time tokyo drift was just
considered sort of like
the the bastard love child of the
franchise because it was rotten it
didn't make as much money as
most of the other films and it was very
separate obviously because it lacked the
stars vin diesel and paul walker for the
most part but
over the years and in no small part
thanks to jen's barbecues
it's become so beloved that the whole
series is now sort of relying
on the backstory of that movie so
without further ado brian hit the music
let's talk about this
there's so many scenes that i'm so uh
thrilled to be able to talk about
because again i did not know this movie
is going to have this effect on me and
sometimes when we're doing a movie like
cats i'm excited to talk about it for a
different reason
jen i i do want to start with you here
what is a movie
scene within tokyo drift that you're
like yeah that's why the audience is
right
and the critics are wrong i love the
drifting scenes
in this movie which were done
practically and i think if you
revisit tokyo drift as i have been
urging people to do
for years now if you revisit and
reconsider tokyo drift which as you said
was
unfairly maligned for so long
i think that there's more appreciation
in hindsight
to to to grant this movie and one of the
things that especially now we've seen
the the movies get bigger and bigger and
bigger
more and more computer graphic based in
terms of
action uh but tokyo drift
all the drifting that you see for the
most part is done
practically they they tapped the actual
drift kings
of the time to do stunt driving so one
of my
very favorite scenes in this movie and
in any car movie is this beautiful
operatic drift up the
the circular garage
in sean boswell's first race against
dk you know what dk stands for
donkey kong drift king
drilled what do you mean drift
it is so cool because that's the race
that that's his first race in
in tokyo once he gets transplanted there
as as jacqueline mentioned in her
synopsis and so
you know that this guy's got some game
he's got a lot of raw talent because we
saw him racing the high school bully
in the opening of the movie but we know
that he's out of his element here and
then when it comes to drifting
jacqueline watching that scene i was
like this kid is gonna need at least
four montages to get this drifting thing
right because the way
that dk who's the the the antagonist in
the movie is hooked up with a yakuza
he's going up the ramp and he's like the
car sideways the whole time but just
through
gears and levers and hitting the pedal
on the gas and steering the right way
and doing all these other cool drifting
things
he is able to get that modified car to
the top and you're like how is this
kid from alabama wherever the hell he's
from
going to be able to replicate that in
real life probably never would but this
is not real life this is the
fast and the furious so i love what jen
said there and i will add to that that
one of my favorite scenes
was the climax when we're racing down
the mountain because it was just so
thrilling i really did not know what was
going to happen even though i've seen
subsequent movies in the franchise
i had no idea who was going to win what
was going to be the fate of the loser
were they going to survive are they just
going to fall off the mountain i just
found that to be so well directed
well shot i instantly wanted to get in
my ford fusion
and go drive up a mountain luckily it
was at night and i didn't and i slept
which is what everybody should do after
seeing any of these movies
take an uber to your next appointment
you should not be trusted behind the
wheel so
it's a lot of racing stuff as far as jen
and i go jacqueline
do you have a scene that can articulate
how you feel and why you feel
the way you do about tokyo drift yes and
i will say this i don't want anyone to
think that i'm just beating
up on the random white boy and this paul
walker was one of the linchpins of this
franchise we miss him dearly every
single day
and he was that outsider coming in and
very much didn't understand the world
that he was getting into
but the way they handled that character
in the original and in other films
was just with so much more care than
what they did with this uh lucas black
character sean boswell it was just not
no
the scene that illustrates this for me
is there's a great scene
it's um it's han and it's sean and
they're standing on a balcony
and the question that anyone who doesn't
understand why
sean is even in this world and even
remotely part of it
is asking it's like why did you hand me
your keys
to your car that opening night why did
you decide to do this
and han gives this like
venus and serena serve of a line read
where he talks about
hey man you know i'm here because i had
to kind of run away this is my mexico
this is me
you know i had to leave some bad things
that happened that's the events of
better luck tomorrow
and i need to know that the people
around me
have some character and that they'd be
willing so the fact that you caught
those keys and would
go up against the dude you should not go
up against that's the guy that i can go
into battle with
why did you let me race with your car
you knew i was gonna wreck it
why not because it's a lot of money
i have money it's trust and character i
need around me
who you choose to be around you that you
know who you are
one car in exchange for knowing what a
man's made of
that's a price i can live with
and it's honestly the best character
development that that character has and
he didn't even say it
looks like and that illustrates why he
is the albatross
of this movie and on top of it all
his acting like we're only like like
you're talking about lucas black
yeah lucas black his acting i'm talking
pinocchio wooden
log cabin wooden i mean han is giving
him
so much like pathos and and
emotion behind it and like look man i'm
a man without a country in more ways
than you can understand
but i'm just looking to find my little
ragtag group of folks that i can trust
and you showed me in that moment that
you could be somebody that i could trust
it's all in him and the other one's just
sitting there
like humpty dumpty and gives absolutely
nothing back
and it was just so frustrating it made
me wonder
what it could have been if the han
character
was the character of sean boswell and
that to me is the movie that this could
have been and i'm sure there was a draft
of this somewhere because justin lin is
a very talented filmmaker
making him an outsider within a culture
is a
much more interesting storyline and i'm
just like i'm lamenting
and mourning the movie that could have
been throughout this movie and for every
moment that i love like the drifting and
everything else i'm just like but why
why is this dude here
yeah i understand i totally understand
uh
we're coming from because this is a
tired trope that we've seen
so many times in hollywood studio films
where a white man a straight white man
has to be
the center of a narrative even if other
characters are more interesting even if
other arcs are more interesting
studio thinking especially back then in
2006
especially when they're two sequels into
a franchise that
at the time they might very well after
tokyo drift just
dump off into direct-to-video land
there's so much
that is probably very beholden in this
movie
to old ways of studio thinking including
the need to anchor this narrative around
a white kid a white man a white guy
and that's why i i really appreciate the
execution
of tokyo drift the execution and how
justin lin came
in and i think probably fought
for a lot of things that fought against
those
those um forces uh of this
of this this the studio system justin
lin came in and brought sun kang in
who he had cast as a character named han
in his previous movie it was an indie
movie
championed at sundance by roger ebert
called better luck tomorrow which
jacqueline
you mentioned people should definitely
see that because it shows you
just a few years before tokyo drift
where these actors wear sung kang where
jason tobin who's also in tokyo drift
and is back in fast nine where they
and justin lin first came together
artistically
i completely agree with both y'all that
i think it would have been much more
interesting to have han be the central
character because
there's a term that i i don't want to
butcher because again i just saw the
movie for the first time last night that
is used by both lucas black
and who becomes his love interest and it
just
it means outsider that you're not jin
yes
that you you may be living here you may
be amongst us but you're not truly one
of us but you also got that feel
with han and so why not just have han be
the one
who is who is going against this person
and and you could keep
everything else in the movie pretty much
the same way because the backstory
between han and dk the fact
that they are in business together and
that han may be pilfering a little bit
even if it's to do good you're still
stealing from a very scary organization
and so there's more than enough there in
terms of conflict and in terms of
humanity because even as the movie plays
out
one of the things that impressed me is
that they did not make dk this evil one
note villain he certainly can play that
but his leering like evil menacing
overpowering presence
gets so much softer once you see who his
bosses are
who's who his family is and so you
actually see
him just be this shy puppy dog after a
while too
so i think the conflict could have been
there the only thing that i will say
about
lucas black is that he jacqueline
i don't disagree with you that in that
scene on the balcony
it's it's totally hans seen and
even in that one scene that's where you
can watch
f9 and be like oh so much of this
probably came from that one
scene from those couple lines but there
is just this weird
odd maybe it's just because he's got
that southern drawl
and i'm from the south too it's just
this like weird off
offbeat charm that lucas black has that
doesn't make him completely pinocchio to
me i think that there is
some real boy within that wooden puppet
you're talking about
i appreciate you being the kind part of
this podcast yet again
but let me just say no no no
no uh-uh i'm sorry and also i will say
that why are women just panty dropping
for him
i'll never understand like that is a
great question
this dude's showing up everybody wants
to be with him like
at least bow wow was charming and like
explained why he had the girls around
him
you know i'm the funny dude that'll make
him laugh what about
this dude with the lear and lack of
driving skills makes you want to be like
oh yes
well that's more again because it's
written that way
right so then the question is why was it
written that way
yeah and i think you can you can apply
that sort of contemporary
look back lens on so many movies that
you probably
already have talked about on this
podcast alone right
oh yeah i definitely get in trouble for
basically being like why
are all these heifers melting for this
dude yes but it's also to me
to me it's interesting to think not that
not that this has directly to do with
whether or not i agree with the tomato
meter on this
but you also look at who was reviewing
things at the time
in 2006 it was still mostly white men
in criticism in major publications
and i wonder if criticism was more
diverse in 2006
i'm not saying i can predict how the
review or the tomato meter would change
but i
i wonder how different the
the the texture of the critical reaction
to this
would have been under those
circumstances i think it's it's also the
fact that
it's certainly that's a big part of it
but you also look at
2006 where we were with franchises and
where we were still putting
stars on the movie poster being the
biggest thing as opposed to the
franchise itself and i think that
it critics by this point in the
franchise it's the third movie to come
out even though
chronologically it may not fit in to be
the third movie it comes later because
some of the after films
were prequels and i would love for y'all
to explain that to me in behind the
scenes talk but
right now it it it almost looks like
they saw the third movie in a franchise
and they said okay wait you're the third
movie in the fast and furious franchise
but
neither one of the two lead stars from
the first two movies
are gonna do this this is all i'm
already discounting this
before i even walk into the movie
because i haven't heard of anybody in
this movie
and so i think that that might have led
into some of the short changing of tokyo
drift too
totally and then look what happened it's
so interesting to me
and i don't know which segment this fits
into really but to me the
reconsideration of tokyo drift has a lot
to do with the
reconsideration of how the franchise
then
evolved after this movie taking along
key elements that justin lin
injected in this movie along with it
that's probably a later yeah it's a
crime stroller yeah it's a crime
thriller there there is a lot of crime
thriller that
underscores this which was almost like
the easter egg in the first movie
you know what i mean like it was mostly
racing and then they're doing some crime
on the side
no we are living in the world of crime
we're racing
although a very important part is almost
like the icing on this cake it's really
about
you know the deeper underworld of like
you know what are you going to be able
to do to afford these cars and
and the sort of sacrifices you have to
make i i think that's interesting that
he set that up
also i just want to add this real quick
too um
justin lin like i just i can't imagine
fast and furious now without his
influence and
although i will rail against lucas black
every day until the day i die
the camera work and the way he framed
this world
you want to get on a plane and
immediately go just dive into this world
you would not make
out of this movie and you can tell
because watching it for the first time
again
the racing scenes in this movie you so
easily you didn't have to have every one
of those shots in that climax race
coming down the mountain you could have
shortchanged it you could have
shortchanged that scene that
ends in what we think at the time is
han's death you
you could have cut corners there but
justin lin just sunk his teeth into this
thing
and he saw that script he's like i am
going to make the hell out of this movie
and especially the racing scenes but
he's also such a talented director
because
he can make a scene that could have just
been dead on arrival
like sorry jacqueline where lucas black
and his love interest
they go on their first date and and they
get the they get the sushi and they're
drinking rockstar which is anything more
2006 than those giant oversized rockstar
drinks no the
the the scene uh rock
the skein underscore with crit kid rock
was where i was like we are really back
in 2000 oh you mean
minute two of this movie right but that
but that scene
when they're on their date i i did feel
a human connection there and so
you know i i totally would buy into the
fact that this movie would have been
better with han as the lead and we
didn't
necessarily need this white guy sean to
be in the movie at all
but that scene i think that it speaks to
justin lin as a director that he's able
to do
these incredible drifting scenes like
jen pointed out we're mostly practically
done but he can also have this quiet
intimate moment
that actually does resonate so he's got
a lot of tools in his kit
jen is there something else besides one
of the drifting scenes that you look at
this movie and you say this is why
dammit this is a fresh movie yeah well
to me
if it is um a movie one of the
one of the many fast sequels that exists
within
genre parameters like you're saying
jacqueline as a crime thriller
but it is also carrying on
the tradition from fest one and fest two
at this point
of really being about found family
and brotherhood and the mentorship
between sean and han that's why we care
about what happens that's also what
drives
the the action this movie treats action
not as not as something
shallow or an afterthought but as
something that has
the potential to carry metaphor and to
advance character
and that is the way that all good action
operates
and it it is laden in in the very
fundamentals
of of uh the sean character
in america in the in the prologue
basically when he's racing
in america all he knows how to do is
race with rage and go fast but
in tokyo he learns that that's not all
that you need
to to really like win and ascend to that
the next level you need to be able to
focus and
um he is a brash american which is the
only other way i would argue
it does work to have a white guy at the
center is because this movie
points out how it points out the folly
of white american male cockiness
yeah he's wrong he doesn't know the best
way
to to drive let alone to race and he has
to
learn and he learns from han which i
think is important
um so to me again a lot of this comes
down to the execution
and the ways that justin lynn
must like that he that he made this his
own
in ways that if you look closely there
are all these really cool things like
you have
real-life drift racers given cameos in
this movie they're literally
included in the texture and the text of
this world
um this is one of the first movies that
i saw that had a cool
asian-american character that wasn't
defined by
his asian-ness being the han character
and that's one of the reasons why
to me the han character has been an
important character
um and also really compelling so so
there are a lot of things
that still work for me really well in
this movie
uh around the narrative and and how the
themes work
how the characters and the relationships
work
and also it's funny in weird random ways
like
bow wow's hulk car who
who would've yeah the whole car and this
is before the mcu was in full swing
kitties
exactly this is coming off of ang lee's
hulk movie from 2004 before the other
incredible hulk that was part of the mcu
but it's a really cool car and i will
give a shout to bow wow because
i i thought he was great i thought he
was so good in this movie
he was perfect although jacqueline i
will disagree with you sometimes the uh
the the funny energetic guy doesn't
always get all the girls just rushing
but he was just so endearing
and anybody i think he's crucial in this
movie for this reason
anybody that lucas so you can be lucas
black
but anybody that gets cool with bow wow
to me or that bow wow gravitates to in
this movie i'm like all right i
instantly trust that person
just as much as han han likes you i like
you bow wow likes you
i like you and i think though that
confluence of characters that i was
already pulling for from the moment
they're on camera
taking this kid in i'm like all right
lucas black sean
you're i guess you're in my crew too
because these two people
like you yeah i loved his character i
felt
um again i just um i know that this was
actually
i mean we'll get into this behind the
scenes written for vin diesel like this
was actually going to be his movie and
obviously i think the han character is
going to be a part of that too but
i i do think that there's an interesting
dynamic if it would have been
vin having bow wow as his sort of like
little
you know sidekick in a lot of ways i
think that would have been a very
interesting dynamic and also still
adding han into it
but it's another testament to me about
how i feel
and i will stand behind what i consider
the lack
of of acting that was given to us by our
lead is he's out acted by literally the
dude
who was best known for hip-hop beats at
that point
like this dude was not you know bow wow
had done movies not saying that he
didn't he
had done movies before this but he's
literally getting out acted
by what some people might consider a 90s
um karaoke trivia question like come on
kid
this is your profession but this is i
mean it must be said this does have
a loki like a deep cast yeah it does
uh leonardo numb who is now
really well known for being on westworld
for example
you have brian t who's um who's i think
really good
as also okay uh you have sunny chiba
yeah a living legend yeah so
and and uh mark you you referred to the
character
neela who's sean's love interest who's
played by natalie kelly
i i always wish that we saw more of her
coming back we see so many characters
come back to this franchise over the
years
and it would be cool to like have her
back in along with suki
yeah yes those are my two on my wish
list
and i was seeing her drift i love that
she got a scene to drift
and it was it was that that point break
sort of scene where in point break it's
the surfing scene where now you're
ingratiated with this
with this new culture but you're also
gonna make out with lori petty because
you're the last two
in the ocean and this one when they're
all just drifting it's this beautiful
night shot and they're going
up the mountain and you see how adept
she is at it and so
it's like well yeah let's have her back
in the franchise we're welcoming
everybody back
it seems like again haven't seen the
movie yet but f9 is just going to be
this
big backyard family barbecue and so get
her back too um i want to add this too
as well because i want to make sure that
that some white boys get their do in
this movie major boswell
give it up for the dad he had like
the only character arcs that this
character was basically given throughout
the story a lot of it came from him in
that moment when he was fixing up the
car
it's expositional it's only there so
that that way they can later
soup up that car for the grand finale
but it's so interesting to see him do it
because it says so much about like oh
this is
how lucas probably you know first became
in love with cars you know like he knew
dad really liked cars he's probably a
toddler handing him
uh tools underneath uh the the head
of the engine head of his car and i
really
i thought that was just so well done and
he's he's a
is an absent dad but he still played
that to where it wasn't
one-dimensional again every character
around our lead has dimension
has character drives the story and this
dude is just like
paper you're right though but but that
is also one of the themes that
reconnects back especially when you see
fast nine
it's really interesting to see justin
lin come back to the franchise in fast
nine
and to see how much in many ways
tokyo drift is a really great companion
piece
not just because of little easter eggs
that make that are connected but
themes like that like fathers and sons
and family and bonnie and
the the also the metaphor the car
metaphor
of how they reconstruct
sean's sean's uh engine
into his dad's car at the end of tokyo
drift
uh so that he can you know assume his
final form
you know all those metaphors could be
very cheesy and
probably some people out there think
that they're cheesy but within the realm
of a studio action movie that was
barely saved from going direct to video
i think it's
actually kind of remarkable that those
little little bits exist
i think that's an excellent point i have
one last quick question before we move
on to behind the scenes because i do
want to talk about jen you're
being at the forefront of the campaign
for hashtag justice for han
and and being somewhat involved in
getting han back into this franchise
but am i correct in assuming jacqueline
and jen you all saw
this movie in a theater in 2006 when it
first came out or did you wait until it
was on dvd
i didn't i did see in a theater
i'm pretty sure like this is what the
problem is is because
i drank a lot in the early 2000s and
mid-2000s and so
girl i got to worry about a midlife
crisis i did enough um
let me so it was either this or too fast
too furious
and the reason why i remember it is
because after the movie
that's what it was it was an alamo
drafthouse triple feature
yeah the alamo drafthouse used to do
this thing where they would do like a
night with something
they've done like the hobbit feast where
you watch all the lord of the rings
and they like feed you the whole time it
was a fast and the furious and i think
it was
um those three films together you could
kind of watch it as like a triple
feature
and yeah because i remember afterwards
people doing donuts in the parking lot
and i've been like
you guys have more sense i'm telling you
you guys have more testosterone than
since there you go make sure you have a
friend pick you up after you see any of
these movies um
the reason why i ask is just because i i
won just quickly y'all's reaction to
that post credit scene that we saw i
guess the last scene in the movie it's
not really a post-credit tag but
when the reveal of vin diesel is there
did that do anything
to you when you first saw it because me
not knowing that's coming
when i watched it this week i got chills
oh my god you didn't know
i had no idea oh i mean i know these
movies were awake
because i remembered han was i all i
knew is that i remembered han
was the guy but i couldn't even remember
if like you saw him escape from the car
before statham does it so
i i had no context for that and i did
not know that bin showed up at the end
but
when when bow wow says another great one
delivered by bowwow when he says
he says he's he's han's family i'm like
i know who it is but i didn't even think
they'd show it i just thought they might
show the car
and then fade to black but no they got
vin back and that's another cool story
to talk about
in a couple minutes but i had no idea
then was was going to show up
that's amazing i'm so happy for you that
you have fun
all right let's get into all this um in
in behind the scenes then because
we have a lot to talk about we have a
lot to tee up so let's hit the music
brian
[Music]
yeah so it's so funny because apparently
justin lin met with vin diesel for like
four hours
one time uh talking event about the
franchise and this is before tokyo drift
was made but
he he just kind of gave in his his
play-by-play for where he thought this
franchise could go
and they apparently mapped out a lot of
it that night but vince still wasn't on
board with doing the cameo
until he secured he didn't get paid for
it he said in lieu of payment for this
cameo
i just want y'all to give me the rights
to riddick back
so he got the rights to the riddick
franchise
back from universal in exchange
for doing this cameo and apparently
test screenings lit up the audience one
of the things is that apparently
the character of han played by sung kang
got
a perfect 100 score every test audience
that saw
this movie loved that character and i
read that it's the highest
test for an individual character in the
history of universal pictures which is
awesome and well deserved
and then audiences also lost their minds
at the end
when the vin diesel did show up so
that's pretty impressive yeah it stuck
the landing
anytime a movie sticks the landing
audiences will forgive it and critics
usually don't care
yeah jen can you just give us a little
bit of background as far as the justice
for han movement and
all the cool barbecues that you do and
why jason statham still isn't invited as
of right now
[Laughter]
um okay so yes uh where do i
there's one thing that you just
mentioned about vin diesel
basically bartering the cameo in tokyo
drift for
the riddick rights that's really i think
that's another moment which
uh in which tokyo drift is then pivotal
in
ways that you probably wouldn't have
been able to to predict back then
because then when the
the vin diesel cameo comes in at the end
of tokyo drift
that predates the avenger the the
that predates the mcu doing something
similar with
credit scenes so and now like
how many franchises do that like
literally all of them
so it was kind of a brilliant stroke to
um
to tie the room together with vin diesel
cameo at the end of tokyo drift
um and also a brilliant i think probably
brilliant
business move on beha on on vin diesel's
part because after that
vin diesel then rejoins the franchise
as the star and fast and furious fast
ampersand furious
which has a very confusing title the
fourth movie that vin diesel
fully comes back for he is now producer
on
and of course now by by now in the
franchise
fast nine we see that he has really
exercised he's flexed
that producer muscle ever since
so in many ways i think tokyo drift
is a really important formative
installment of this franchise both on
screen
and behind the scenes it's very
fascinating to me but justice for han is
something that's that
a couple years ago caught on on social
media
i cannot take credit for it but it was
something that
i thought was important to to
amplify and the reason is twofold
hashtag justice for han
right was the hashtag um when fast seven
came out
and in fast seven if we all remember by
this time the death of han
seen in tokyo drift has been now sort of
rehashed many times in the franchise
it's been retconned which is another
thing that this franchise did
um really interestingly that other
franchises really haven't done
retconning is is i forget what retcon
actually stands for
nerds it's it's pretty much when you
take a wedding div
played by michelle rodriguez and you're
like oh no she didn't really die
like rewrite you rewrite the past so
that you can move on
in like a new on in a new trajectory
you duck tales it you rewrite him
life is just a mystery um yes
so hashtag justice for han came out when
fans of the han character saw what was
done
to the han legacy within the canon of
the film
of the films which is really interesting
at one point you have
a reveal where just jason statham's
character
is introduced as han's killer as the guy
who really was actually responsible for
for t-boning han at the end of tokyo
drift
and you're like oh my god what a jerk
and then he becomes the the villain in
the next installment
well then by fast seven
the franchise employed jason statham's
character differently
by giving him a redemption uh he saves
vin diesel's he saves dom's baby and
in return gets an invite to the family
barbecue
now i think that rang very untrue
for a lot of fans who like
dom would have would have would have
would have uh
protected the memory of han and what
that meant what he meant
to the family and so it felt like a
little bit of a betrayal hence
the hashtag justice for han and so for
me i wrote
i was like just really happy to get
justice for han stories into the l.a
times
um and the headlines in the early times
uh because another thing the the other
dimension to justice for han
is that when you do something like that
to
even an inactive but core member
of a franchise ensemble who is the only
prominent asian character in
a franchise like this it feels dirty
it feels it doesn't feel right it's kind
of like what jaclyn's saying about
you know like everything she's pointing
out very rightfully so about the optics
of even tokyo drift you have to do
better
as a studio as a filmmaker right
especially when so much of this
franchise's success
has been built around the idea of family
well
what does that mean when you say well
actually
han this character who else is one of
our only
asian characters persistently in this in
this franchise
when his death doesn't mean that much
so i think that's i think those are the
reasons sorry is long-winded but i think
those are the two reasons why
people wanted to see the franchise do
better for him
but also by that point the this
franchise had shown
um a willingness to embrace what i would
call soap opera
logic where anything is kind of possible
you know like as you mentioned letty
came back you know like you're always
perfect evolving dude superheroes with
carburetors instead of capes
and so if you can believe thor's hammer
if you can believe that captain america
had super soldier
you can believe that han and letty are
back also i will just say
it's the it's the expendability of
minority characters yeah that's what
what jen was kind of touching on it and
and granted they
luckily because of the internet and and
justin
lin has been very forthwith to say that
internet virality and how many people
were
were passionate about it and people like
you jen and other writers who wrote
about it
uh so eloquently is what allowed them
to then make this a thing because to
your point this was a character that
they had already dealt with they did not
need to do this
but they wanted to and so they really
did i mean you got justin wearing
justice for han
uh t-shirts on set like this dude was
playing
into it and it does show the power of
fandom can do good
yeah it's really interesting yeah a
couple quick notes about that too so
first of all uh
brian perez our incredible engineer uh
chimed in in the chat with
retcon stands for retroactive continuity
and so you're going back and you're
changing how the continuity works so
brian
once again that's why i buy you beers on
the comedy store patio
and if if you look at the mcu again
this is this foundation was built before
the mcu and so while the mcu
is celebrated for having some measure of
diversity i would still say that
the fast and furious franchise inc has
the most inclusiveness that you will see
in a major
hollywood studio franchise and i don't
think that it's the
the next closest is all that close i
think if this is a race
then i think that fast and furious is
beating everyone by a wide margin
what's really cool about this is that
the two things is that making this movie
they had to do a little guerrilla style
shooting apparently because
some of those downtown shots they got to
tokyo that you were not allowed to get a
film permit there
and so justin lin literally and people
signed up for this he didn't make people
do this but they would be shooting they
knew they had about 20 30 minutes to get
a shot
and if the cops showed up they would
tell the cops that somebody
else like a pa production assistant was
the director
and they would take them to jail so they
would have to spend the night in jail
but so that justin lynn himself
would not have to go to jail this
happened
six times making this movie six
different people played the role of
justin lin going to jail so that
justin lin the actual director could
continue directing the movie
which is bonkers to me and then the last
little stinger is that after this movie
comes out
and justin lin and sunkang are hanging
out they're driving somewhere in
california
they stop at of all places in arby's
which is my road trip go-to
apparently they get out of the car in
arby's and there's a bunch of teenagers
hanging out and they all recognized
han from tokyo drift and that is when
both of those fellas knew hey this
really was
culturally resonant this is a touchstone
and
maybe it just i'm not saying it planted
the seed but maybe
it fertilized it a little bit to say we
need to get han back in the fold here
yeah i think there are two things that
you just touched on there that i want to
point people more to
um the story of justin lane lynn
having stand-ins on set in tokyo
who could be arrested in his place
because they were stealing
shots gorilla style is one of my
favorite
tidbits about the making of tokyo drift
um
which he shared at a q a that i
moderated at the new beverly many years
ago
that the writer stephen saito wrote up
on his website
the moveable fest so you can go read
steven's recap of that entire q a
because there's so many more delicious
amazing really fun couldn't happen ever
again especially in 2021
stories about the making of tokyo drift
in that
also did you catch the mc hammer cameo
in tokyo trip no i noticed the posters
when he first gets to tokyo and he's and
he's on the escalator i see the posters
of m.c hammer is hammer himself
actually in the movie no that is the
cameo
and but that was deliberate that was
that was put there
in appreciation because m.c hammer
helped save justin lin's
indie movie better luck tomorrow i did
know that
he came through with with funds so that
justin could finish that movie which was
his first
solo directing feature after justin lin
had randomly met hammer at like a trade
show or something like that
so i like to say i like to put this out
to remind people
the fast and furious franchise as we
know it would not exist
if not for better luck tomorrow if not
for justin len
if not for also m c hammer yeah
that's why so many of those titles have
two in it like too legit to quit which
is
you know from the mid 90s so to this day
justin lin
prays just to make it today there's so
much great stuff
behind the scenes of this movie and and
we touched on some of it the last thing
i'll mention
is the cinematographer of this stephen
winden also shot
deep blue sea so we all bring it back to
deep for our buddy
oh i have one um jack i was gonna ask
you if you have any last tidbits on this
uh behind the scenes of this movie that
just you would not think it when it came
out but has just spawned so many great
conversations and
i i this has been another one of them so
this one is related more to justin lin
and sort of his better luck tomorrow
fast saga because for folks that don't
know
because of justin lin better luck
tomorrow
is considered part of the canon
because the characters are the same
although universal wouldn't
agree to that if you probably asked them
if you asked justin lin
better luck tomorrow is the prequel to
the fast saga and literally
technically kicked it all off but the
thing i will mention about this um when
we talk about
asian representation better luck
tomorrow is a crime movie
um in which the characters do some very
nefarious things
and we talked about roger ebert
championing that movie because let's be
honest without better luck tomorrow
being championed by critics like roger
ebert at that time justin lin does not
become a director
who can then get the movie sold who
could then get the movie into theaters
and could then go on to do
greater things it's all linear and it
all relates to that and an early review
can
literally put you on a path to great
things
so it's not just a review that that
roger ebert contributed
the story is the story is wild and it's
magical sundance film festival stories
yes they take better luck tomorrow to
sundance and it's a huge moment for
justin lin it's his first feature it's a
huge moment for the cast of young actors
who went on to great things including
sung kang
john cho um and at
one of the screenings at sundance third
one ward one
oh my god jeff i'm on it third one
details on
her facts at the third screening at
sundance somebody in the audience q a
stands up a
white a white man yes white man i
actually don't i don't think
i've seen the video it's a white yeah
there's a video on youtube who
stands up to shame the filmmakers
for making a movie that made asians look
bad like as in
how could you do this to your people
kind of thing the whole entire point of
better luck tomorrow is that it dispels
and in fact
implodes the model minority myth which
still persists to this day
um around asian americans um
it's about teens and it's based on a
true story too a true crime
it's about a bunch of overachieving
teens who get bored and
break bad and start doing crimes and it
escalates out of control
and at this q a this man stands up to
berate
the filmmakers for how could you do this
and then roger ebert
stands up and the video again is online
and says they should be anybody should
be able to
make whatever story they want and he
defends this movie and because of that
the um the longtime film publicist
david magdale told me many years later
he was working on this movie because
again this movie was such a
a community effort david magdale
specializes in lifting up the asian
american community and
and filmmakers of color at the time at
sundance it was before
the era of screeners it was way before
the era of
screener lynx they got such a bump in
visibility from roger ebert
standing up to champion this film and
defend its right to exist
that the entire a
hard-working pr team cleared out went to
that one grocery shop that everybody
goes to in town in park city
cleared out all of their blank vhs tapes
and scrambled to make
copies of the film like press copies
they could put in critics mailboxes the
next day
and then they got you know they got
distribution eventually and
it launched so many careers but it
really does speak to you as jaclyn's
saying
the importance of of critics not just
covering but
but championing and standing up you know
like
if we had more of those ebert stand-up
moments
imagine yeah it is a big moment yeah
such an incredible
story and hearing it is so inspiring
that my sports card collector brain
immediately goes to how much are those
vhs tapes worth today if you can get one
of those i mean
you could probably finance another fast
and furious movie with that i mean that
is
that is such a cool collector's item and
and such a worthy
thing to champion that and this has all
just been such a great conversation
again from a movie that a lot of people
thought was
was an afterthought when it came out was
as jen rightfully said i mean in in
danger of almost being
this this direct to video directed dvd
sort of sequel where
it ends up being so important in the
greater
franchise that makes billions and
billions of dollars for universal so
a lot of fun here we we're going to move
on now but i do have one quick trivia
question that we're going to ask on the
other side of our mailbag
so brian let's hear that music
all right so this is from our esteemed
member of the ketchup crew which is what
we call all of our
lovely fans out there across the world
alex hellyer
he says hello from down under friends
hello alex you don't know me but i feel
like a wallflower to your friendship and
that's enough to make me feel like
we're friends my wife and i recently had
a boy which we named mark
after listening to this podcast not
really we called him
i was literally about to be mark man
making waves
you know what it i think alex probably
knows that would have put way too much
pressure on me so thank you alex for
naming him dax
hours continues but it's given me a lot
of long nights to finally watch the
extended editions of the hobbit
rotten tomatoes is wrong alex is here
for the campy
three stooges quest of the dwarves and
middle-earth war
and then he says mark has got to be with
me come on mark you're sincerely
alex hellyer alex unfortunately
because you named your kid dax and not
mark i did not have to be with you
i i'm not with you yet but again i have
not watched
the hobbits uh the extended editions
in depth while caring for a newborn i
just have a very frisky
14 year old dog that is running around
the back
of my curtains so i have not
investigated them but
maybe it is something that our podcast
can revisit
once upon a time so quickly before i i
we get out of here jen you have these
these legendary
fast and furious themed barbecues that i
just wanted to get a quick
question in about you started this and
you've done a barbecue theme for every
fast and furious movie
you've seen fast nine without giving
away any in-depth spoilers to the movie
do you have you already had that
barbecue is it planned is there going to
be a specific theme
look if you're fishing for an invite
mark yes you're invited
oh my god this is great i know it hasn't
happened yet because we're also in a
pandemic people
yeah come on are barbecues even
happening i don't know i actually don't
know i think barbecue should happen more
than some of the other things happening
at least most of those are always
a thousand percent a thousand percent
facts
anyway but i i would i'm with it i think
you should go to a
a gen karaoke party first though mark
because jen um since we were talking
about film festivals i might also add
both jen and i
are film festival frequents and love
every chance that we get to go it's one
of the things i'm missing most about
this
pause that we're in and jen is a karaoke
goddess
like i'm literally serious like she will
do bonnie tyler she will do celine dion
and she will bring it
i will do celine dion and i will do the
titanic song i don't care who's out
there
in the audience it's my time it's my
time when i'm up there and i will
i will sing my heart will go on and jack
jacqueline has the voice of an
angel rumor has it that's why i see
i'm i've been doing stand-up long enough
to know i in no way am i going to do
karaoke if i have to follow you two i'm
happy
to open and just as an homage to tokyo
drift i'll do that kid rock song
whatever he's racing today no
that's okay no no no no no no
why bring that scene up for this reason
because the one trivia question i have
about tokyo drift involves that opening
scene
when sean played by lucas black who
jaclyn loves
is racing the high school bully can you
name
the child star or the tv sitcom that
that high school bully
starred in in the mid 90s yes obviously
do you have any harder trivia questions
i know
that was it uh i know it's zachary
and he was in he was on home improvement
another series that should stay in the
90s
zachary ty bryant yeah and he was who
he was the older brother on home
improvement was it brad was he brad
was he bro yeah he's right he's brad
brian brian gives us confirmation that
he was brad we were all watching jtt
anyway did anybody i was watching home
improvement
no but you were watching for for
jonathan taylor thomas like did anybody
care about brad
i didn't catch that yeah i was watching
for jtt yeah
and that doesn't beale christmas movie
yeah okay i'll be home for christmas
oh my gosh yeah most folks would make
the assumption that mark once his family
got out of the air force and settled in
virginia that we loved home improvement
if that show was on and my dad was in
the room he made us turn it off he hated
home improvement for some reason
he could not respond to home improvement
and you know what i've never given
it a full watch but from what i have
seen i think
old mark ellis was right i think was
was mark senior himself a tool man is
that he was not a tool man no
he just he just did not like the show
and upon
the limited re-watching i've done of it
i think he was right
it just didn't hit didn't hit me didn't
hit me
more of a uh friends martin seinfeld
kind of 90s kid
with a shout out honorable mention to
the fresh prince so
thank you so much jen yamato this has
been such a just an enlightening fun
conversation to have about a movie that
may have never crossed my radar i could
have gone on seeing these fast and
furious movies forever when they
inevitably cross over with dinosaurs or
volcanoes or outer space
and i never would have known the
importance or how much fun i would have
had watching tokyo drift so
i am just thankful to you and this
podcast for giving me that opportunity
where can everybody check out the stuff
you're working on with la times
with all of the many things that you
have going on
um you can read me in the la times you
can listen to me i actually
would love if people would check out the
podcast that i did at the times called
asian enough which
exists to center and share asian
american stories
sung kang was on it in our first season
last year
and his story his personal story is
really cool i encourage people to hear
about how he went from
being a georgia kid to being in the fast
and furious franchises
dying many times on screen in this one
franchise alone
and now coming back so uh i highly
encourage
people to check out uh also his i don't
have a movie recommendation really
right now but i do have a podcast
recommendation that is sung's
podcast called sung's garage which he
launched last year
and you were on an episode of that i
believe is that right i was talking
about justice for han
yes which was wild it's like you have
barbecues
you you have your first fast and furious
barbecue
your second one is called and by you i
mean me my second one was called
too fast two barbecue of course and the
third one was
fast and furious barbecued drift the hon
loo memorial
barbecue wow hon loo memorial we
recreated the memorial
um oh life life-sized memorial that you
see at his funeral scene
um and i explicitly
banned anybody from bringing jason
statham to this barbecue
still on time out from my barbecues
we'll see
how that goes well yeah in the future
keep jacqueline and i posted on when the
f9 barbecue is
if there's a spare seat i would love to
occupy it and i will raise
a corona whatever dom toretto uh
allows us to drink and i will get very
excited about
being there on that special day it has
been a blast as always y'all if you want
to be like alex you want to be a member
of our ketchup crew
you can email us anytime rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com
rt is wrong at rottentomatoes.com let us
know what you like about the show
let us know your comments your thoughts
and of course your recommendations for a
topic we should talk about
on a future episode wherever you listen
to us we appreciate if you subscribe
you rate review whatever your platform
advises you to do
we urge you to perform that task and
help us
get even higher up in the ratings so
wrapping up the show here for our entire
hard-working team behind the scenes here
at rotten tomatoes including brian perez
our engineer producee lucy the one and
only
our amazing guest jen yamato my esteemed
co-host jacqueline coley i
am merely mark ellis saying uh go check
out
f9 but don't do it until after you see
fast and furious
tokyo drift we'll talk to you next week
[Music]
you